it's very tempting to just make this
four minutes about me gushing over your
performances i hope you two know how
incredible you are in this movie thank
you so much
very much mean it uh madeline i wanted
to start with you i was just curious do
you and your sister really like horror
because the two of you are in some of my
favorite horror releases of the past few
years now yes we love her we love going
to hollywood horror nights at universal
studios we want to go again this year
it's so exciting i think it's both it's
because we both love that heart drop
feeling but we love watching scary
movies together because then after we
get scared we can just laugh about it
all right i like that approach to it i
know she's younger than you but did she
give you any advice jumping into this
especially after having done uh hill
house and dr uh sleep i know right um
but probably because i was i guess i
would say i was a little scared because
it's a horror movie and she was like you
just have to remember when you're
watching it it's all fake because she
does get scared at times too even though
she knows it's all fake but it's like
it's not scary when you're on set but
then when you watch the movie it's
terrifying
signs of a very effective film when the
star themselves actually finds the movie
in the end scary all right so mason for
you i've got i got two-parter on this
being your very first big role in a
feature film so first what is something
about you know being on that set that
felt right to you that even though this
was the first time you've led a feature
you were standing there and you're like
i got this i know what i'm doing and i
belong here yeah i i think most of
that's from coming from of course maddie
and
she's so incredible everybody on that
cast and crew is
super nice it kind of felt like i was
joining a brand new family and
everybody was super incredible and it
was such a great opportunity and i'm so
glad i got the chance to do it all right
so to flip that around a little second
part here what is something about being
the lead of a feature film on this that
you know came with a little bit of a
learning curve where you took something
away from it that you're eager to apply
to your next film that is a good
question i'm
i'm not 100 sure i mean i love the
character finney so much and
you know getting the opportunity to to
be a lead my first film is is incredible
and i'm so happy that i got the chance
to do this
and i i yeah i love the black phone so
much and i can't wait for everybody to
see it
one heck of a start for you in lead
roles right here for both of you now i
mean this movie is just filled top to
bottom with scenes that seem very
challenging to me so was there any
particular day on the filming schedule
that you know had you circling it in red
and saying this is the day this is the
scene that i'm most nervous to shoot
yeah they're
there yeah for me i don't know i think
there was two or maybe one because i
love doing stunts so getting to do all
the technical physical scenes was really
fun but probably my most intense scene
with jeremy davies who plays terence our
dad in it that's the one i was i was
scared and excited and
i don't know i think it turned out
amazing on camera yeah for for me it was
definitely a ton of scenes with ethan
but there was the climactic battle where
i was super
super excited and and kind of scared to
you know do it but watching the film it
turned out great so
that it did again exceptional i mean it
from the bottom of my heart
congratulations i can't wait to see more
from both thank you so much
you